hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna watch
a movie trailer for a film called the
birdman' birdman there's no thought
behind it anyway I'm gonna watch this
trailer SARS Michael Keaton who is a
scene stealing actor who doesn't get
lead roles anymore oh poor guy
but it's nice seeing a lead in this one
and I don't know what this movies about
but a lot of people have been
recommending that I check this isn't it
out so let's watch this let's watch a
man turn into a bird I hope this will be
good sometimes at night I turn into a
bird think about all that places I go
France Italy Chinatown
he's depressed no that's like how did we
end up here in this dump you're a movie
star remember
Oh Emma Stone
go back one more time to show them were
capable
what did you get your wings in your
house a cool cast I'm not familiar with
the director but the film does look like
it could be interesting I like dark
comedies like that you know ones that
are like hey it's funny but moody and we
need movies like that we need a lot of
movies like that because life is not all
about laughter people there's darkness
and the light and there's light in the
darkness
that's why interracial couples are cool
you know what I mean
anyway guys if you're new to this
channel you can subscribe if you don't
want to subscribe I understand you don't
have to leave such a mean comment I mean
if you want to leave a mean comment sure
you can leave a mean comment but if you
don't feel like it give it a shot let's
see what you can see what I can add I
want to do some shout outs here I want
to mention this guy the Emanuel Neves he
said last comment he left me I've been
waiting two months for my shoutout
that's what this guy says he's waiting
for two months that takes dedication
ambition hard will Veronica knock it off
for making too much noise
come on camera and perseverance and
that's the debt qualities you
demonstrate tonight my friend you are an
American Hero
not really
Dante Ramirez he said can you shout me
out in our trailer reaction I don't
really know if he gave me a shout out
well I don't keep track of these shout
outs what do you think I am huh yeah I
don't know if I give you a shout out I'm
not I don't have like a you know
Microsoft Excel worksheet on this stuff
like I should I just you know if you
request it I'll just give it or if
you're awesome I'll give it or if you're
really hot I'm going to give you one now
your thumbnail doesn't resemble your
looks at all and pleasure your guy if
you're a good-looking guy so say
something
wally west he
had shoutout me next before I rape
someone
really really rape earlier I talked
about perseverance and dedication this
guy takes it to a whole other level
Wally don't rape anyone